Israel's plan to deliver Swift Justice
to Hamas terrorists now facing push back
from President Biden the Administration
has been saying Israel has a right to
defend itself after suffering the worst
terror attack in its history but now
America is urging the Israelis to delay
ground operations into Gaza while safe
passage for the Palestinians is secured
we're making sure Israel has what it
needs to defend itself and respond to
these attacks it's also priority for me
to urgently address the humanitarian
crisis in Gaza we can't lose sight of
the fact that the overwhelming majority
of Palestinians had nothing to do with
Hamas and Hamas is appalling attacks and
they're suffering as a result as well
what worries you about a potential
Israeli ground Invasion into
Gaza President Biden wants Israel to
slow up but times crucial when Hamas is
holding 150 hostages Israeli forces is
launching targeted raids into Gaza to
try to find those captives Israel also
giving 1 million gazans 24 hours to get
out ahead of a massive ground Invasion a
Netanyahu spokesman says the country has
been making it clear that they don't
want to harm any
civilians the people of Gaza know their
cities they know their communities
better than I do better than you do they
know where they live they know where the
the Kamas strongholds are they know
where the arms deco depos are they
should move away they should move away
even if Hamas tolds them don't move away
move away stay out of the combat
areas we have no interest in harming you
uh uh please you have time not much but
you have time move away some
Palestinians fleeing Gaza after Israel
dropped leaflets telling them to get out
while they still can but Hamas wants
Palestinians to stay in the
area
Hamas are telling their people we're
telling the people to move and the
people are not moving they're saying
don't move and that's how people get
killed Mass right now have told their
people to stay not to move that is part
of their cynical
methods I'm getting the feeling judge
that Biden's keeping Israel on a very
short leash if he's already signaling
pump the brakes when they have it even
officially begun the ground Invasion
okay and you know Biden it's interesting
that you know he has the ability to say
pump the breakes given the 29 countries
are over there and most of them have
taken out their own citizens and Biden
hasn't uh but did the Israelis get
24-hour notice did the Israelis have the
opportunity to defend themselves and to
move out the truth is Hamas is telling
them not to move no other Arab country
is interested in taking the Palestinians
and the amazing part of it is Hamas
should have had them out Saturday night
after Hamas did the attack on Israel
they should have said you know what
Israel is going to hit back let's take
care of our people but this is the whole
point the Palestinians are nothing more
than a pawn in the game that Hamas and
Iran are playing and you know Egypt
ruled Gaza from 48 to 67 and then when
Israel took Gaza over in 2005 they said
to the Palestinians you can have Gaza
back and they elected Hamas they elected
Hamas in 2006 and 2007 Hamas was not
interested in defending or taking care
of these people and nor do any of the
Arab countries other of them want them
Egypt doesn't want to let them out out
either Egypt doesn't want them in their
country so now we have a delay Biden
wants us to delay wants Israel to delay
what does this do it's worse for the
hostages Hamas gets the benefit it plays
right into their hands and you know
we're we're in a situation that's almost
no win now because the world is going to
come in and say you know we're farther
away from this everybody remain calm so
the US Congress Herald is very
supportive of the Israeli ground
operation I can't see any way that the
Democrats and the Republicans are going
to try to have Netanyahu slow this thing
down until they rooted out these Hamas
terrorists why is Joe Biden add on a
limb like that well it's good to have
you back and good to be back with
everybody again I don't think he is is
as far out on the limb as you think I
think he is made clear secretary Austin
was there secretary blinkin was on the
ground today uh making clear that you
you stand with your friends and you
stand behind your friends and you you
run to your friends in a time of of
peril and this is indeed a time of peril
I think the primary concern of the
president and I think it's a valid one
is that if this escalates meaning if you
the more Palestinians you kill the more
likely it is that Hezbollah will invade
from the north and if that happens you
have a a mass massive escalation in this
which we obviously know the Iranians
have some part in this and they are
supporters of Hezbollah as we all know
which means that this thing would
escalate even more so I think that's how
I interpreted what the president said we
have not at all said we would not send
weapons in fact the real hold up is that
we don't have a speaker in the Congress
hopefully they do that sooner rather
than later so we can appropriate and
spend the money to extra money that we
need but whatever the president's able
to do it's my understanding he has done
it but I think it's right for him to to
lay this out for one other reason for us
to be able to deter Iran we've got to
build this Coalition out even more and
get them sturdy so the Saudis the
Egyptians the jordanians are critical to
this obviously the signers of the of the
Abraham Accords to UAE and Bahrain are
critical to this the more they stay with
us the likelier it is we're going to be
able to detour Iran because the only
reason Hamas did this was because the
prospect that Israel and Saudi would
Forge an agreement that would further
isolate the Iranians and further
strengthen the Saudi and for that matter
bring about A New Path for
reconciliation and shared growth in the
region so I take the president I I
interpret him slightly differently than
maybe well it would help that Alliance
if the president would tell all of these
Arab Nations maybe take some of these
Palestinian refugees that is true that
would help a lot that is true your
thoughts on President Joe Biden today
well it's interesting that every US
president basically ends up having to
deal with the Middle East this President
tried very much to leave this whole
thing behind he went to the periphery of
the Middle East pulled out of
Afghanistan didn't really make any
efforts to broker a peace deal in the
Middle East which many presidents have
he sort of didn't touch that didn't
invite prime minister Netanyahu to the
White House until the very last minute
and even now um they met in during the
um meetings here in New York and said oh
yeah please come by the end of the year
okay that that's all that has happened
so far in terms of of having that
meeting so the problem is that what the
now I think these countries that were
involved in the Abraham Accords I think
they would like to see a strong arm
against Iran and now we find oursel
because they don't want to do it and
they don't want to say it but isolating
Iran works for them as well I think it
was very interesting in Brett's
interview with MBS the Crown Prince of
Saudi Arabia um he said well of course
we have to address the Palestinian
situation um but it wasn't you know fire
in the belly in terms of the way that he
talked about this so I think there's a
real opportunity here but the other
thing I sense from from President Biden
is the restraint issue is kind of
parallel to as long as it takes in
Ukraine and now the United States has
its hand on the tiller of two enormously
important situations so basically we are
the lead supporter in a two-front war
one in Europe one in the Middle East at
this point and this is an
extraordinarily consequential time I
think we're at a turning point for the
United States I think that this becomes
the central issue of the 2024 election
and I think it's going to be a
referendum on on leadership and who can
take us through this next series of
really important consequential world
events so we're in a proxy war with the
Iranians and the Russians commander and-
Chief Joe Biden we were talking last
night on my show Pete that everybody
needs to understand this is going to
take a while because of these tunnels
that are so deeply entrenched underneath
the Gaza Strip why hasn't President
Biden conveyed that this is maybe going
to take not days not weeks but perhaps
months and months because we what we saw
from the podium today uh was a
reflection of an instinct from this
Administration from the very beginning
which is bothsidesism you saw the Tweet
deleted from the Palestinian office
inside Jerusalem you saw the statement
from blinkin that was pulled back about
both sides and restraint that's the
Instinct of the modern Democrat Party
that's why if this referendum is about
which Administration would handle it
properly you've got the Trump
Administration with no Wars and none of
these incursions and peace Visa now two
open land Wars that were trying to steer
in a direction uh and doing so very
poorly by the way we have us hostages in
Gaza y United States citizens in Gaza it
should be Joe Biden only at the podium
saying hey Hamas try it and you'll find
out hey Egypt we don't want civilian
casualties take them take them now and
because you're supposedly supposed to to
be a partner in all of this because BB
Netanyahu has to do what he has to do to
secure his people and he has an
impossible as we laid out last an
impossible situation in Gaza considering
what Hamas has done considering the the
uh hostages it has the tunnel system uh
the the built-in fortified defense the
International Community just waiting
just waiting to broadcast and then an
Administration prepared to jump into the
both sides ISM that you saw all already
today I hope BB Netanyahu does what his
country needs and doesn't listen to the
squishes Pro Palestinian Millennials
inside the state department and inside
the White House whose reflex is to be
Pro Palestinian at this point and not
pro-israeli but just In fairness he
didn't say don't go nor did he say I'm
not going to send but hold on beginnings
of the rumbling ter no but but hold on
the United States is fully behind Israel
in this effort if when you're partners
with someone you you can say to a
partner hey we think you should think
about this in a certain way I don't
think there's anything but understand we
we're giving them everything they need
if you give me one the only reason we
can't give them everything they need
Congress even use the word Iran they
can't even say we're going to claw back
six bilon so let me ask you this
question just think about this if we go
in the way you're saying we go in and
they don't even listen to what we're
saying and Hezbollah attacks on the
North they have
150,000 Rockets be afraid of them for
the rest of time by no means but we
should certainly consider it as the only
point I make let me be clear I'm is
considering that he doesn't wantah to
invade from the north either so that's
part of his
calcul that Yahoo has a mission and he
will do he will determine mrah has not
said anything to the effect that
America's not giv him everything he
wants in fact the only reason we can't
do this and I hate to say this because
it may offend someone Congress needs to
get back in session and appropriate
these dollars okay period all they'll
get what they need and the amount of
money we give the Saudis the Egyptians
and the jordanians we can move some
people around and I think everybody
knows Joe Biden could do it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else